all right Knight f6 all right
BOGO Indian or nimzo-indian right here
Bishop here BOGO right here knight here
Bishop here NIMS oh all right and this
is the Leningrad isn't it I want to
first have this Bishop declare its
intentions okay at the very least I can
grab this night room white structure and
they don't have a dark square Bishop
around so in other words I could have
obtained an imbalance that I believe is
favorable for me it has a structural
damage and they don't have a bishop pair
as compensation for it or do I just
maintain the pin with Queen takes and
then focus my sights on d4 with moves
like c5 and if it takes then this could
really be a problem I think I'm gonna do
that I'm not gonna take the knight as
follow-up so I'm gonna run with this
let's do right now that night is still
pinned to pinned piece powerless and now
okay only after being provoked am I
gonna consider taking now however might
I do better to first take on d4 and only
then take the knight if pawn takes pawn
takes Bishop on takes Knight I end up
winning material pawn takes pawn if
Queen takes now I take and then there
ends up being double isolated see pawns
which I will later try to target by
playing a ruck on the C file I'm
investing a lot of time right now
because I'm trying to forecast a good
sequence of moves that will enable me to
then devise a good middle gameplan and I
think I do well to first take here
taking right here right now allows pawn
takes and then if I take then
recapture and the pawns are uncoupled
that said I think I take here first I
would much rather these pawns be double
isolated and I think that that's what
we're gonna see or if my bishop is taken
we're gonna have a situation where I'm
going to be up material pawn takes
Bishop on takes Knight pawn takes pawn
queen takes pawn and actually it's going
to turn out to be more than just a pawn
up and this knight would then be having
to run backwards because the Queen block
would not be there because the pressure
I would have from c3 with my Queen on
this rook I think the best continuation
just to immediately recapture in d4 so
how is that going to be done I think in
either case I just grabbed this tonight
with my bishop and then play against
this structural deficiency
okay a lot of time being chewed up but
then again I chewed up a lot of time so
oh wait I don't actually it doesn't
matter
or does it now I'm gonna take this I'm
gonna take the Queen first and then take
the knight and now where would I want to
have my knight c5 like a six to c5 where
there exists isolated pawns there exist
homes I'm looking for that one that's
something I said earlier in the stream
if you weren't in here or even if you
were here I still say I still said it
whether or not you were here
I still said it okay I might want to be
a little bit concerned about this pawn
coming down if I play b6 this pawn can
engage with my beep on I only have a few
more moves to really focus on and then I
can rattle off more faster I believe I'm
gonna go with this I did think for a
split second about going to c6 but the
knight takes and then because I have a
pound on C it's not as easy to get at
these guys so if Knight here there is no
threat of a fork on c7 I'll probably
just bump my king up to e7 my fault
moves I'm not considering castling it
I'll forget about it who cares about
castling going to e7 is sufficient he's
more centrally located King e7 d6 I'm
not sure where I want to go up my
LightScribe bishop I might want to go to
d7 I might want to take the time to play
b6 I think it's better to maybe just go
with b6 Bishop e7 but in the meantime
what is this Bishop gonna do is it going
to be causing me a problem on this
diagonal with g3 Bishop g2 we're not
having that and maybe before this pawn
could somehow clamp down on this square
I should probably move
you know let's do that this Nike go
human target this pond but I am pretty
sure I did the calculations correctly
night here King e7 rook d1 rook d8 and I
don't know if there's additional
pressure that could be placed as a
follow-up I could then be run with
Knights e-file let's go here I could be
running with Knights e5 if the night is
on b5 I could play Knights e5 followed
up with a 60 the night away and now I'm
in a position and get developed and
eventually put pressure on this pun I
might also want to play to a4 you'll
note that there's homes on these squares
as well this the c-file net squares the
files there's homes on the C file as
well as the a file pawn push release has
a threat on my night but I just capture
and now just go here and double Brooks
on the C file and then this is going to
be very difficult to defend let's go at
this one so that in the event that my
king is attacked or something there's
not gonna be any you know king being
stuck in between my rooks so that's why
I went with this one instead of this one
roof c7 rook a to c8
my knight is being attacked but I feel
like I've been in a similar position
before like this I'm gonna avoid the
exchange for right now and just put
pressure on this guy this guy and I may
also want to reroute my bishop to a6
we're gonna see about that
homes this is very awkward now to have
to devote a piece to the defense of a
pond we're evening out timewise so now
what its pile up on these weak links
time rook H okay we're not having that
double rooks okay strictly defensive
mode before I go here I'm gonna go here
for a brief second I was thinking as
soon as I play here there's this pawn
push but that is not the case because I
can always take that pawn and defend my
bishop if I didn't have that available
pawn push Bishop takes Bishop is met
with first Bishop is met with first pon
takes pawn with check or even pawn takes
here on my rook but we don't really have
that going on so now I want to just
eliminate one of these two and then this
cannot be held how can I get my knight
attacking this pawn again for a second I
thought go to c5 b 7 a5 but what's wrong
which is playing here immediately I know
what's wrong I know what's wrong there's
that pawn push that's available that's
okay I'm gonna do it I still get this
pawn at the end of it I would still get
that pond at the end of it this isn't
the cleanest approach maybe I could have
just done some some move where this pawn
push would not be available and if it's
not played I think it's it's an even
cleaner approach to the rest of the game
okay that is being played now I take and
now I'm just winning upon so there had
to be that in-betweener but it was not
played and so now it's more than just a
pawn that's being lost this one's going
down and probably this one okay now
let's hit three times pawn push just
runs into a pin and I can really pile up
on it even more I have enough defense on
it and that comes with check those were
the weak links and they are
they are following past ponds they're
connected
push them it's going out a little bit of
a snail's pace but my rook is enough I
don't even need my king support to get
these pawns advanced as soon as the rook
place to the C file I just scoop my king
over little by little I'm this pawn I'm
gonna take him just coming back over
here is good enough inching my way up
little by little with check on push pawn
push again and then rook here okay
and pond push away I'm actually having
better success with these moves in this
browser with moving fast and that Mouse
slipping which is refreshing
all right good game let's go back and
take away something from this because
the the bulk of the game where the game
was where the battle was won and lost is
with the very very early decisions
because of the resulting structure as
soon as you ended up in that structure I
really do feel that it was just a matter
of time before they just started
dropping those weak links on the C file
so how to avoid that is the big question
one way to do that is to just run with
the classical line that classical line
says Queen c2 in this position just
preparing to challenge the bishop with
a3 and after Bishop takes Knight you
recapture with the Queen you do invest
some time in doing that you do pick up
and imbalance and night for Bishop
exchange black does have more rapid
development but it's something to look
into if you're gonna be playing Bishop
to g5 and after h6 if you take this
Knight I think it's safe to say that you
cannot claim any advantage because you
have the white pieces if anything maybe
you are to backup to h4 but taking the
knight really I it's hard for me to see
that it it grants white any advantage so
back up if anything if you were to back
up I was gonna be playing moves like c5
and thoughts of Queen a5 so I think it
could start to become very sharp and
maybe it's a bit uncomfortable right
because of the pins and me excuse me
striking at your center so if this isn't
comfortable with you or if you're not
comfortable with this
look into the classical line Queen c2
something I could learn a little bit
more about myself on both sides so once
here this is this is trouble
8-3 is probably not the way to go maybe
it's best to just support your Center
with e3 and then just make way for your
Bishop to develop as soon as it's double
isolated see pawns this is big trouble
this is very very big trouble
you have no compensation for it I was
saying earlier sometimes black will
impose this structural damage on white
but white could then say it can come
back with well I have the bishop pair of
you don't have that there's no
compensation for this so that's why I'm
focusing on these first dozen moves were
really the the tables do turn so if the
very least should it get to this point
assuming that you did still run with the
bishop takes tonight which I do not
recommend look into this
III move support your Center make way
for your light square bishop to come out
okay